du rugby sans les bobos c'est la
promesse de cette formule à cinq joueurs
ces disciplines qui compte plus de 2500
licenciés à travers la france est en
pleine expansion depuis deux ans pour
surfer sur cette dynamique le rugby-club
de versailles a ouvert un créneau mixte
le samedi matin en octobre dernier nous
avertir voulu créer cette élection parce
qu'on trouve que ça l'intérêt pratique
en tout cas d'attirer les filles vers le
rugby puisqu'on n'arrive pas à
versailles tiré les cheveux et rugby et
puis c'est sympa de retrouver des
d'attirer des débutants et aussi dans
des 100 sièges joueurs qui ont joué
avant qu'elle ait marre des contacts et
du coup qui retrouve maintenant le
plaisir du ballon ovale rejoint toucher
les règles développé par la fédération
française de rugby sont simples les
plaquages sont interdits le jeu est
arrêté dès que le joueur est touché des
deux mains par un adversaire tout ça que
c'est vraiment un jeu d'évitement un jeu
de rapidité
l'objectif bertin qui prend de vitesse
adversaire pour reprendre la pièce
l'adversaire notamment celle de relances
de jeu après le touché
tout ça va être simple de d'aller
marquer ça je rame un jeu de traite pas
très technique bt qui puisqu'il faut
savoir faire des longues parce qu'on a
50 m à gérer à cinq depuis la création
de la section loisirs 15 joueurs
débutants aux confirmés d'autres fils
sont inscrits il ya une ambiance sympa
c'est un jeu quoi c'est plus c'est
peut-être moins cela n'est que le rugby
a qu'un c'est ce qu'on s'éclate passage
tout le monde peut participer les filles
et les garçons les jeunes les moins
jeunes
c'est physique il faut se dépenser on
peut pas y aller à moitié il faut juste
y mettre avoir de la bonne volonté et
puis la pratique bien le rugby club de
versailles espère attirer entre 40 et 50
licenciés d'ici deux ans et participer à
des compétitions régionales dans les
prochaines années